One really awesome take away message about facial expressions is that they
don't only express emotions, they can actually amplify and regulate emotions.
This is through what's called the facial feedback effect. This is the tendency
for facial expressions and the muscle activations that cause them to actually
produce a corresponding feeling, such as happiness or anger. Now, I want you to
try something. Grab a pen. If you don't have one, press pause and get one. And
take this pen and put it between your teeth, like this. Doing this activates
the muscles that make you smile. Then, I want you to grab the pen again and
hold it between your lips, like this. Doing that activates the muscles that
make you frown. If I had you watch a video with a pen between your teeth like
this to activate a smile, and then watch another video with a pen between your
teeth like this to make you frown, do you think that would actually affect how
amusing you thought the video was. Yes or no.